now as Australia's favorite maths
teacher who also happens to have one and
a half million subscribers on his
YouTube channel Eddie Wu is the perfect
choice to co-host Paramount's latest
show on Tim ultimate classroom let's
welcome the always inspiring and totally
fabulous Eddie woo back to studio
so great to have you here okay I can't
believe it's taking you this long to get
your own show because your wood tube has
been going on for ages and people love
it the kids love it obviously one and a
half million people follow it
um this new uh show takes you inside the
classroom and science to the next level
so how tell us about how this
competition works so it's so exciting to
have this opportunity to really showcase
brilliant STEM Science technology
engineering and maths um students we've
got teams of them every episode they
compete in various challenges and the
winner of each episode each team they go
into the finale which we are super
excited for people to see oh wow my
daughter loves science uh what kind of
challenges do these students come up
against this is all about making science
technology engineering maths come to
life in practical ways so for example
flying drones piloting coding Building
Bridges seeing how heavy we can make
things it's a lot of fun very practical
oh look at these pictures
um you guide the students through the
maths elements of the competition but
there are other Specialists to help with
science Science and Technology and
Engineering as well we have some
outstanding mentors from the Australian
Defense Force it was great having them
on hand actually because they are the
best embodiment of how all the skills we
talk about and that knowledge we
actually make it Hands-On and we can
solve really complex problems and
they're just the perfect people to give
that advice wow that's great yeah you
can't do it all on your own your co-host
in the show is a gaming Guru Stephanie
ashwan is that working together uh she
is an absolute delight and even though I
mean I've done a little bit of TV here
and there but the classrooms where I
feel at home so having a trained
professional like her really bring the
kids along and the energy she had was
outstanding that's great now you've
helped kids everywhere fall in love with
maths which are woo tube channel I mean
I love I love maths we watch it all the
time and do any of the show challenges
well I'm not very good at it there's a
place for everyone that's all good do
any of your own challenges feature there
yes absolutely in fact one of the things
that we did on the show was I would
always give a lesson for each challenge
to really prepare the teams and even
though it's a really Punchy short TV
show we couldn't include the whole
lesson but if you go to YouTube you'll
see it there uncut it really can learn
along with the teams and have a lot of
fun with them oh and so what are you
most impressed by when it comes to these
kids ah just their teamwork and their
insight and their complex problem
solving so it's not just about how much
you know it's how you can actually come
together look at something and think
what can I what kind of creativity can I
apply to this problem and they were just
always endlessly surprising loved it
what do they win oh so I'm a big
believer in spoiler-free experience
you'll just have to tune into it and
find out did you pick the winner from
the side oh look actually this is one of
the things which I love when you have a
watch you'll think oh I think it might
be them think it might be them but you
kept guessing right to the last moment
oh I've got a classroom it's hosted by
Eddie Wu and it is Sundays at 6 30 on 10
shake and 10 play and then it on calls
on Friday at 2 30. Saturday at 4 P.M
Sunday at 3 P.M right here on 10 no
chance of missing it anyway thanks for
coming in always a pleasure bye awesome
why would you